today we're talking about cloud domains
network connectivity center and
recaptcha enterprise i'm jen and welcome
to this week in cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news
we created cloud domains with the goal
of simplifying domain related tasks and
we've continued to build on that initial
release with new functionality
cloud domains allows you to manage
access controls for domains through
cloud iam and manage your domain
registrations and renewal through cloud
billing for a more seamless experience
with the rest of google cloud head to
the blog for more functionality and to
get started
network connectivity center our unified
network connectivity management solution
is generally available in 15 regions
across the us uk india australia and
japan
and we are on route to expanding this
coverage to include all google cloud
regions enabling global on-ramp to the
cloud
we are committed to maintaining an open
and flexible cloud networking
environment that will enable
interconnectivity with the google cloud
network and partners play a critical
role in this check out the blog for
details
recaptcha is a security product and has
always thought to be hard on bots and
easy on humans as bots have gotten
smarter we needed to adjust to keep this
balance so in this latest version of
recaptcha recaptcha enterprise we've
created a new detection method that
provides a frictionless experience for
users but is still effective at
identifying bots to learn more about our
two primary principles protect users and
provide a frictionless user experience
check out the blog
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud